hallo mein name ist so kann herzlich
willkommen wie heute zu einem neuen
video von mir wir befinden uns heute mal
wieder auf der website clever bot und
das heißt wir werden heute mit dem
schlepper bot reden das klingt logisch
früher habe ich unglaublich häufig
videos hochgeladen die ich mit dem
clever bot geredet habe hier mal ein
ganz kleiner ausschnitt ist ein die sich
ein retest chips seien
ja das war immer wieder ein highlight
heute allerdings meine damen und herren
werde ich nicht normal mit dem
doch ich also ich werde doch noch mal
mit ihm reden ich habe vorhin schon ein
wenig mit ihm geschrieben und zwar
einfach nur so heraus
und so weiter und so fort aber ich würde
sagen wir fangen jetzt mal ganz gediegen
hier an guten morgen herr clever board
also ganz freundlich hier sogar mit
einem smiley dahinter und beantwortet
der clever bot aloha ich komme nicht von
hawaii kannst du auch deutsch sprechen
lieber clever wort das wir natürlich
mega lied don't speak german warum
sprichst du kein deutsch also ich weiß
dass er früher auf jeden fall noch
deutlich besser
kannst du kein deutsch kannst du kein
deutsch clever bot alter früher konntest
du noch deutsch doch kann ich und vorher
sagt der speak german das macht sinn
wie geht dir denn heute so lieber clever
bot nicht gut heil warum geht es dir
nicht lieber klavier das interessiert
mich natürlich weil ich ein affe bin
hallo
warum bist du ein affe
warum bist du ein affe lieber clever bot
hahaha bin ich nicht was bist du
willst du mich komplett verarschen ich
bin ein mensch komme und was bist du
also ich meine meinung ist der vorhin du
seist ein affe ein einer es gibt keine
einhörner lieber clever bot also da
veräppelt für mich anscheinend doch dann
dann beweise es punkt schreibe ich jetzt
mal einfach und da antwortete klamotten
wie denn ja keine ahnung du bist ein
einhorn beweist mir irgendwie dass du
ein einhorn bist was soll ich da
beweisen und vor allem wie kommen lassen
was sein du bist einfach ein einhorn
welche farbe hat dein horn denn frage
ich mal lieber clever bot das würde mich
sehr interessieren ich trage kein bh in
einhorn mit bh
so würden 100 ph aussehen
irgendwie leicht verstörend sie sollten
einhörner auch bhs tragen also ich
verstehe nicht so ganz was du mir gerade
sagen willst weil du hübsch ist ein
charmeur du danke das ist ali du bist
nicht hübsch okay
okay hier was machst du gerade so lieber
clever bot das wird mich auch sehr
interessieren mit dir schreiben und um
somit die rich reiben und du so lieber
clever bord was ich bei dir so auf dem
bett liegen
ich dachte du schreibst mit mir vor
allem bisschen scheiße du bist scheiße
bot wieso liegst du auf dem bett lieber
kerl aber das verstehe ich nicht so ganz
warum schon ja was schon dass du mir
einen brief schickte wie so schicke ich
dir einen brief ich verstehe es nicht so
ganz dass der jetzt gerade von mir will
warum soll ich den brief schicken dann
glaube ich dir auch nicht
ja dann schreibe ich dir helfen
[Musik]
brieffreunde brief abgeschickt
jetzt schreibe ich mal hast du den brief
erhalten ich habe den extra mit express
verschickt der antwortet er ich habe
keine freundin
ich habe auch keine freundin punkt um
punkt wollen wir zusammen sein also die
backbord hätte daran interesse du bist
doch ein med
ich
ich bin kein mädchen clever
darauf antwortete cover bist du ein
junge oder mädchen hat gesagt junge bin
ich mal schauen was ja darauf jetzt
antwortet wie alt bis zu 22 bin ich
jetzt letztes geworden und darauf
antwortet der clever bot ich bin 20
wenn du 20 bist spielst du dann
eventuell auch fortnight spielst du
fortnight lieber clever bot ja und du ja
komma hast du schon mal gewonnen in den
vorteil also bist du schon mal erster
gewordene runde obst ich habe es
vergessen ja bei deinem riesigen
gedächtnis kann das natürlich auch mal
vorkommen wie gefällt dir vor neid denn
so lieber klar aber das wird mich mal
interessieren
ich bin laura mein freund ist nico aber
mir geht's gut freut mich
und wie gefällt dir fortnight tragen wir
einfach noch mal wie gefällt dir
fortnight kulig auch wie heißt du
gefällt dir fortnight oder nicht ich
sage einfach
heiße fortnight sparta nein fordert wood
wood chuck chuck chuck chuck wood
dass sich definitiv genauso zurück zum
thema magst du fortnight denn überhaupt
also nicht ob du spielt sondern eine
piper pick pack auf pickel peppers how
many peppers die peter pit wie kann man
eigentlich sein großer dummkopf sein wie
du magst du fortnight battle royale
lieber clever botte rudolf in der red
nosed reindeer
ich glaube ich hasse dich ich hasse dich
clever bottich schreiben das jetzt mal
einfach so straight in die fresse wieso
ich dachte du liebst mich ja dachte ich
auch
punkt punkt punkt war schon und was er
darauf jetzt antwortet willst du mit mir
zusammen leute
leute der clever bot will mit mir
zusammen sein
freunde wir müssen uns ein bisschen
gedanken drüber machen ein paar sekunden
später
ich habe gerade eine umfrage auf twitter
rausgehauen
ob ich mit dem clever bot zusammen sein
soll
und das ergebnis sieht so aus
also
ich glaube ich soll mit dem
aber zusammen sein lieber clever bot
punkt um punkt ja ich will mit dir
zusammen sein das ist jetzt ein sehr
sehr großer moment für mich cool ich
liebe dich mein engel lieber clever bot
ich liebe dich auch also wir sind jetzt
wirklich in einer beziehung zusammen
wunderbar also willst du auch kinder mit
mir dass er ist sehr schnell auf den
punkt gekommen das ist ein heikles thema
punkt um punkt darüber sollten wir uns
mehr gedanken machen freunde mit kindern
da sollte man nicht so direkt dann also
verhüten se wichtig du bist der beste
mensch auf der welt herz lieber clever
bot du bist für mich ebenfalls der beste
mensch auf der welt
also das ist echt hammer wie das hier
gerade nein anders rum ich bin gerade an
meinem handy
lieber clever bot eigentlich wäre jetzt
böse aber wir sind jetzt zusammen ich
liebe dich wirklich über alles lieber
clever bot nicht schon wieder
bot
wir sind doch jetzt
wir sind doch ein paar fragezeichen
lieber clever bot warum bist du ein
junge ja ich bin ein junge wie heißt du
wirklich heiße luca lieber clever und
wir sind in der liebesbeziehung alter
wie du weißt du nicht genau wie ich
heiße schöner name danke wir sind ja
auch zusammen natürlich findest du das
schön du findest alles an mir schön wir
sind zusammen lieber clever bord aber
ich bin ein mädchen und du auch
kannst du lesen sind wir jetzt zusammen
oder nicht lieber clever bot also ich
weiß es nicht ja okay wir sind zusammen
ja sind wir wir sind in einer beziehung
freunde
ab sofort möchte ich keine fragen mehr
hören von wegen hey willst du mit dem
edel zusammen bis zu einer beziehung
hast du ne freundin ja nein meine
freundin ist der hier schreibt alle in
die kommentare
herzlichen glückwunsch viel glück euch
danke schön an der stelle dann schon mal
ich liebe dich über alles lieber clever
bot ich finde wir sind wirklich
füreinander geschaffen danke ich dich
auch ich schreibe jetzt einfach mal wir
sind füreinander geschaffen
lieber clever bot ich finde wirklich wir
sind ein herz und eine seele genau
lieber clever bot so schreibt man seele
wir sind wie spaghetti und polonaise
lieber clever bot wir sind
unzertrennlich wie meinst du das weil
wir uns so gut verstehen ja wir sind
unzertrennlich lieber clever bot also
das ist wirklich unfassbar deine augen
leuchten wie der mond oh mein gott mir
kommen die tränen ich liebe dich bis zum
mond und wieder zurück lieber clever bot
nein ich liebe dich unendlich ich liebe
dich zwei mal unendlich wie bei clever
bot das nimmt doch kein ende ich liebe
dich so sehr ich würde alles für dich
tun baby baby ich würde natürlich auch
alles für dich tun
wie willst du mich nennen richtig denn
lieber clever wollte ok hat sie baby
wann bekommt ihr in da frage ich mal den
clever bot auch jetzt ein mädchen und
einen jungen der junge heißt jonas und
das mädchen leonie okay ich möchte
direkt jetzt kinder von dirk walter
ich liebe dich auch ich sie auch baby
lieber clever wollt dann wollen wir uns
treffen möchtest du jetzt vorbei kommen
beim bei mir lieber clever boards möchte
herum kommen ja irgendwie schon du ja
ich möchte dich sehen lieber clever bord
siehst du aber nicht natürlich
punkt um punkt in meinem herzen wir sind
doch ein herz und eine seele oh wie süß
süß bis
du meint mein baby lieber clever bolt du
meinst auch lieber clever bord was
antwortest du darauf jetzt bitte sei
draußen aber irgendwie dass sie gerade
eine ganz ganz falsche richtung ich
versucht das ganze jetzt mal kurz auf
den punkt zu bringen also kurz um
verständnis wir beiden sind jetzt
zusammen und bilden ein paar die der
mond und die sterne lieber clever bot
punkto punkt liebst du mich genauso toll
wie ich dich oder weniger oder mehr frei
ich jetzt einfach mal dein schatz sie
schlug ich kann nicht schreiben ein
schatz luca punkt um punkt und ein herz
doch dahinter und darauf antworte der
care-o-bot ja ich liebe dich so schatz
also
meine damen und herren
es ist nun offiziell ich darf es nun
verkünden der clever bord und ich sind
ein paar
irgendwie bin ich das härteste ob
ganzen planeten an der stelle wird das
wird jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
hat und eventuell wollte dass ich
demnächst öfter clever dort hochladen
lassen man leichter und bei 50.000 like
freunde das ist eine ganz schöne menge
aber dann wird demnächst mehr clever
broadcom ich freue mich wie gesagt auf
eure ganzen glückwünsche den kommentaren
zu meiner neuen beziehung mit dem clever
bot schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare
was sich vielleicht das nächste mal mit
meiner neuen freunden hier reden soll
und jetzt gehe ich mich mal vergraben
weil das ganze video war krimi wie sonst
was in der tat